hey everyone
pumped
i loved i am a strange loop
by douglas hofstadter
it's been a couple years since i've read
gerda lescherbach
and he definitely
hit another one out of the park with
this one it was fantastic
and it actually has a lot to do with
awakening
as well taken in from a very
scientific angle it's pretty cool
so let's dive in i'll be sharing with
you
my notes from the read and i hope
that it brings you lots of insight and
value
so this is a nexus of self
self-awareness
consciousness self-referential structure
his writing's not over technical it's
not overbearing he stays close to the
surface of real
life at all times matters of the highest
level of abstraction
so this is very much why we
love douglas so much and he's influenced
us so much
transformed the most abstract and
complex of thoughts into a digestible
idea fun and interesting
self-referential structure of
consciousness multifaceted examination
of what an
i is
so some epicness
up front prepping you
so i would start things off by
highlighting
how consciousness is a mirage
made itself out of nothing disintegrated
back
into nothing
you can tell we're already getting into
it right off the bat
so energy self looping
and break the chain see what remains
meaning that we spend so much time
with this sense of self indoctrinated in
this
sense of i and what happens when you
break the sense of i
what remains a self-referential
structure
a strange loop okay so now you have that
as well
consciousness self-referentialist theory
so again consciousness as a
self-referential
mirage very profound
that in itself is basically the core
thesis of the book
consciousness as a self-referential
mirage
douglas specializes in thinking about
thinking exploiting analogies metaphors
galore talking directly
about our own experiences
to earth the highest level of abs
abstractions
so critical examples are typical of most
people's lives most people understand
abstract ideas most clearly if they hear
them through
stories i love hofstadter's focus on
analogies and stories and relatability
it's
core essence of mine as well
i am a strange loop my best my own best
shot at describing what the human
condition
is
what just plain being is all about
he's very much like a intellectual
father to me and many others
consciousness has bodies bodies don't
have consciousness
so it's the formless that has the form
so the formless is the underlying
structure you can think about that as
electromagnetism
you think about that in many different
ways
we're going to be using what the law of
one
calls the seven densities of
consciousness throughout the book as a
reference as well
a seeker of truth who suspects
consciousness is an illusion
is eighth density versus seeker of truth
who believes in consciousness is reality
as seventh density so meaning the god
state of seventh density
understanding that one infinite creator
and the very eighth density
of recognizing that even awareness love
light at play with itself
is in fact an illusion
comprehension of the universe is
happening on a gradiented
spectrum of self-awareness
comprehension of the universe is
happening on a gradiented spectrum of
self-awareness
higher animals those which are able to
think are alive
creatures with souls as true life
the soul has the ability to think what
is thinking
the purest thought is the knowing the
purest knowing is
of the knower
it is conviction understand what knowing
is
i know i am habit guides your thoughts
don't reduce your will awareness to a
collection of complex reflexes
unfreeze your will from reflex
it's basically what the buddha taught
incrementally unfreeze will radically
purify subconscious and merge with
creator
as an interesting play on the law of one
and ross three steps of know yourself
except yourself become the creator
here you can view it as incrementally
unfreezing your will
radically purifying your subconscious
and then merging with creator
soul shards
don't see names see god
i wasn't wondering about its name farm
animals don't have names
different levels or sizes of souls
again density
small sold versus large sold so soul
density and consciousness evolution
awakening
so the i dissolving before death is
awakening
so the i as the person dissolving before
death
is god is union with god
so the small self the contracted person
dissolving
into the god state is awakening this is
what is meant by die before you die
merge with god before you die
people in the final stages of
alzheimer's disease are essentially all
gone
and i wrote here that they should not be
president or running companies
so this is an important visualization
so what you have here is you have that
that retinal matrix
for the pupil and the eye and then you
have the very
sunlight so this can be viewed as a
black hole as well as the sun
so the retinal matrix and you have the
pupil and the iris
and you have perception and so
here you have what is known as uh
ignorance which is when there's a tiny
dim
light on this is when you're just a
creature
and this is when you have the maximum
light on this is what's called knowledge
and that's when you know yourself as god
you know it all as god
so universal awareness love light
increases this is called the
shift from person to god awakening
and that's this is gradiented on a
spectrum of self-awareness from creature
to god
as densities and awakening
so this can be viewed as a consciousness
cone
atlas carto consciousness that's
something i've been using for a little
over a year now
it's a good term so you can see this
is what you could say is enlightenment
right
analyzing and awakening neural lattices
so for example you have the atoms
viruses microbes mites mosquitoes bees
goldfish chickens
bunnies dogs
and then brain damaged and
normal adult humans
and so it's gonna be important to
recognize
that these in a sense
are the awakening of creation
to itself the awakening of life to
itself
that's what's called emergence so
the core part though is the human
density this third density of human life
and this big shift that's happening into
this fourth density of love this heart
chakra
opening up green center and so when you
look at things like
the neural lattices being analyzed and
awakened what we're talking about
up here is we're talking about
the normal adult humans that have these
overly constricted default
mode networks of operating and that
their subconscious is driving their
lives
and they're not even aware of how
attached they are
to their eye and all of these attributes
and appearances around their eye
and all of the other eyes in their lives
and so awakening neural lattices is
a lot about
the process of
the person releasing the grip
on their default mode network into a
more entropic state of disorder
so that they can have a more
creative connectomics
that are more interconnected and that
way their
their little artificial barrier of
separation the little cage
it melts and dissolves and they merge
back into the oceanicness
which is what they are and what gave
birth to them
and what gave birth to all life
this being just one of infinite
explorations
so here's another way to view the same
thing
so you have the eye that's steadily
increasing here
thinking expression so again there's
this
matching density ladder on the left and
you can see
rock plant animal so density 1 2
2.5 then you have this third density
with human ego and separation then you
have
4 which is love five which is wisdom
six which is the unification of the two
and then
seven which is this god unity oneness
and then this eighth which is this black
hole absolute
what we emerged from what everything
goes back to
and what continues eternally exploring
infinite possibility
and so when your eye gets to this level
what's happening is
you become the essence of the entire
creation you become the entire universe
itself
and so your identity shifts to the
universe and you recognize that you
share your being with the entire
universe
and so there's no longer separation
between you and the universe meaning
you see that one infinite intelligence
even in all of the other individuals
that you talk to so you see them as you
and so then the only thing that's left
to do is just to serve creation
awakening
so these maps are really important
so it's a special kind of subtle pattern
that underlies and gives rise to
i a light on interiority being conscious
i think about thinking
it's a good place to just check yourself
as well is
how often do i think about how i think
how often do i think about my frames of
life
and my reactivity
am i incessantly being triggered
or do i have equanimity do i have
freedom and is that enabling me to have
more sovereignty more will more choice
in my actualization and my realization
my deepening
of my union
so the heart is abstractions
it's central so you have things like a
concept
memory analogy memes
and i and you see how these are much
different
than when you look up here and you see
things like dna dendrites and neurons
the left hemisphere completely different
than concepts memory analogy memes and i
so this is these high-level abstractions
are much more of the essence of
what actually is most present
for us ain't nobody right now thinking
about
any of this stuff but you're very
clearly
hearing my words and registering them
and cross-referencing them with all
these other symbols
and then extracting out the most meaning
that's applicable to you
so high level mental properties vast
abstract patterns
was there truly something referable to
as
i
so think of dynamics large scale
structures and patterns
how people make choices versus mentality
small scale phenomena like
neurotransmitters
so juxtaposition between thinko dynamics
and metallics
love your neologisms douglas
another one of the the favorites
and there's lots of references to kurt
gerdel in here
these paradoxical self-referential
sentences like i am lying
another simple one the two mirrors
create this infinite infinitude of
images an
infinite regress
this sentence is false
so an endless
corridor so we'll continue playing on
this analogy at the very core
of each galaxy a beautiful circular
black hole
and so we'll also make a reference
visually for you that will be helpful
how that relates to i
the galaxy analogy so deduced
from the basic loop an infinite fractal
comprehended by consciousness
so i first person
existing having experienced qualia
my goal here is to combat the strident
inner voice
negotiation between inward bound and
outward bound
signals
a repertoire of symbols triggered
so what is the nature of human
interiority
what is each human's experience of
eyeness
how rich is the sense of self how
conditioned or
empty this is really important
how conditioned is your sense of
highness
perpetually triggered or how empty is it
how well can you hold equanimity how
well can you be
free and then what revelations does that
give you about
your eyeness
what is the nature of a mosquito's
interiority what
is a mosquitoes experience finest how
rich a sense of self
is a mosquito endowed with
so here we play with this more a low
level empty self
is no symbolization be hyper conscious
of all that is
god infinity yet be utterly transcended
black hole empty and can you do
both those things simultaneously
and we'll have more visuals unpacking
that shortly
lacks perceptual category symbols
altogether self perception loops
low level
and this is typically what you'll see
with awakening
is you'll see
an absolute absence of symbolization
and con concepts memory
and the ability to draw on memory or
concepts as symbols as you please
but being completely will and sovereign
and choice and aware about that process
rather than being triggered by
conditioning
so emptiness is a big key there the
practice of emptiness
penetrate mainstream perceptual
processes symbolization
streams to iga so iga here is igniting
global awakening
and penetrating mainstream
perceptual processes means all of those
neural lattices that we were talking
about
in this third density and
all of their symbolization streams
so there's a perpetual
perceptual process and symbolization in
the mainstream
and in order to ignite global awakening
it's mission critical to penetrate into
those
mainstream neural lattices and catalyze
awakening
again perceptual processes
biological ladder of perceptual
sophistication it's another good way to
put it
so here's another way to phrase what
we've been talking about where you have
point one is being a polymath so you
have this very enriched lattice
that's infinity and then the point two
is the black hole you're untriggerable
you're empty
so you want a polymath black hole or a
black hole polymath
so imagine if you're a black hole
polymath
you're empty untriggerable
you can radically have zero memory zero
concept
zero symbols and then as you need
just like on a desktop which will bring
up this analogy again later
you can access any of those memories
concepts or symbols
like a polymath and bring them into the
world
so it's an enriched untriggerable
lattice so an enriched
polymathic untriggerable lattice
so guide dogs rich internal category
systems repertoires of triggerable
symbols
initial spark eyeness more complex
senses
accrete snowflake that grows around a
tiny initial speck of dust
level of complexity creature starts
applying categories to itself building
mental structures that represent itself
starts placing itself in some kind of
intellectual perspective
in relationship to the rest of the world
does that sound familiar
my friends
it's a pretty solid way to break it down
okay so it's like an untriggerable
episodic memory and this is where your
emptiness practice comes in two to five
seconds just stop
fixating just use your breath
and stop fixating on objects and
perceptions and sensations and instead
just be aware that you exist
whoa i'm conscious i'm aware
i exist i'm present cool might that be a
formless
quality
so untriggerable episodic memory is when
you're not triggered by this private
storehouse of episodes
of us and our friends and characters and
novels movies we've seen tv news clips
etc
to not being triggered by those memories
so i'm kind of also simultaneously
walking you through awakening at the
same time
it's pretty interesting you're getting a
cool little treat
concepts memories produces a self model
extraordinarily deep entangled deep
tangled self
model is what ines is about so i
is a deep tangled self model
pretty easy i is a deep tangled self
model
and so in essence awakening is the less
deep and tangled yourself model is the
more awakened you are
but at the same time you want to be a
polymath you want to know a lot about a
lot of different things
and so you want to make these novel
polymathic connections
and implement powerful planetary
architectures
but you want to do it from also having
elasticity where you can come to
emptiness as you please
as a perfectly clean desktop
and then as needed step up architect
with your files
so as you think so you are perception
defines
reality thinker dynamical
shift from person to god equals
awakening
so here again is that empty infinitude
that black hole sun
where you have formless infinite
consciousness
while you have a form finite separation
so the form finite separation thinking
that that's the reality
leads you to ignorance whereas
knowing knowledge being a gnostic being
is union with god with absolute
which is your truest nature which is
formless infinite consciousness
patterns perceives define its reality
[Music]
what is realist to each of us in the
end i undeniability
elusive receding shimmering rainbow
it's cool because the mirage or rainbow
analogy to the self-invention
of consciousness how conscious this
hallucinates itself into existence
though especially the rainbow aspect to
that it reminds us a lot of the
nermanakaya from zokchen buddhism
and that's when you're expressing
yourself purely
from that emptiness purely
in your expression
to serve the rest of life awakening and
it's effortless
and so it's cool to draw that analogy
between them
so consciousness as an epiphenomenal
illusion
the concepts of self and i
an abstract pattern gives rise to what
feels like a self
it's pretty direct guys an abstract
pattern gives rise to what feels
like a self
just meditate on that
so creature behavior desires wants
i an all-powerful and yet non-existent
so funny
[Music]
spend your whole life with i and then it
dissolves
it's so trippy
so consciousness god quality
formless power to know and then you have
the traceless comprehension as the
absolute the black hole receptivity
abstraction upward shifts closed cycle
i love this m c escher's drawing hands
reality is recursive and simulates
itself into existence
whoo the procedure calls on itself
[Music]
so there's the eternal riddle of what am
i
self inquiry atma vichara
profound joy discovering patterns
understanding what lies behind
patterns relentless search for why
defines the nature
pattern cannot merely be a coincidence
why what is the reason behind this order
whether or not
anyone ever finds the reason there must
be a reason for it
nothing happens by accident existence of
a perfect pattern irregularity that goes
on forever reveals something is going on
behind the scenes
mathematicians consider it a sacred goal
to seek that thing
uncover it and bring it out into the
open finding a proof
same thing with metaphysics baby
we have to rely on reasoning to get us
there because
infinity is very different from any
finite
so use reasoning to understand that we
are infinite
proofs are guaranteers of truth where
there is irregularity there is a reason
einstein god does not play dice nothing
happens without a cause
always one unifying underlying cause
unshakable
faith
beautiful infinite pattern but for what
reason one single compelling underlying
reason behind
all these infinitely many independent
facts
lies just one phenomenon so one truth
one ocean underlying all of the ten
thousand things
provability truth
recursive reality fibonacci numbers
recursive definition
where there's a pattern there's a reason
infinite defined through recursive
organic growth of an infinite structure
or pattern
a strange loop lurking inside the
labyrinth
palace of mindless mechanical symbol
churning meaning lacking mathematical
reasoning
and that same thing can be applied to
your life
is there some sort of mechanical symbol
churning
that is happening is your will frozen
in some sort of scripted behaviors use
the breath
create a pause and create more
equanimity and create more freedom
create more degrees
of freedom for yourself create more will
and more sovereignty and more choice for
yourself
and be less conditioned and triggered by
all of those symbols and concepts and
memories
in this eye
we'll have some more visuals for that
soon
these are also important these
visualizations
a dream within that dream is another
dream within that dream
is another dream
and so to see these recursive
auraboric
images art illustrations
is mission critical for it to become
more of your own norm
to recognize that that is the case
but that is the truth all meaning comes
from analogies
actually douglas has argued that analogy
is the core of cognition
and i do agree with him quite a lot
analogy is also one of the core ways to
understand the highest level
abstractions
i indispensable ingredient
self-referential
illusion so i is necessary the illusion
of i
the mirage of consciousness is necessary
it's the tool that we use to explore
all possibility to explore infinity we
use this mirage of consciousness
so in a sense
you become like a reality modeler
you're trying to model the nature of
reality so this is infinity modeling
itself
so what are we doing right now we're
trying to model ourselves
how funny is that so a metaphysician
is trying to model the nature of reality
so model the play of reality itself
source pattern reason
galileo the book of nature is written in
the language of math
girdle one of the domains that math can
model is the doing of math
itself so you see the recursion now
and here's a little visualization
so infinity referencing itself
generates emergent properties requiring
a new vocabulary to describe them
so here's a visualization of infinity
referencing itself via the hallucination
of i
so does that make sense everyone
i love you
[Music]
i
so cool infinity referencing itself with
this mirage of
i you see we use the i
as a tool
so every possibility will be explored
and we're using the i the mirage of it
to do so
so i'll read you a couple
more distillations
several of which
are synthesized from
many other
ways of seeing the nature of reality
so the fact truth that you're an
infinite intelligence is unprovable from
within
its finite explorations
so god an infinite singularity is
unprovable from within its explorations
right and so this is playing on how
with kirk girdle we're talking about i'm
unprovable
is true so the kirk
girdle is unprovable in the principia
mathematics
and kirk girdle is true
so another way of saying this
that's really simple and i'll get to
these other examples
is that infinity is unprovable infinity
or infinity is true
so here you are here's a relatable way
to say this
the fact truth that you're a ps5
is unprovable from within gta
okay so for the masses that should have
made sense if you're
in a game world like grand theft auto
you can't
prove from within grand theft auto
that you're actually a ps5 playing
infinite games
okay that should make sense
and just contemplate on it if it doesn't
expand on
it
and so you can also look at things like
this when was the last time you
took on the essence of the universe to
try and understand
why you exist you don't do that very
often
why not why don't you turn inward and
wonder
what's the essence of the universe why
do i exist
so the fact truth that you're in a dream
is unprovable from within the dream how
are you going to
prove from within the dream that you're
in a dream
good luck
you're in a dream looking for factual
truth
that you're in a dream
so another simple way to say this
relatable for mainstream you're in a
virtual reality
trying to find the source code within
the game world
not going to find the source code
in the game world you're not going to be
the character in grand theft auto that
then finds the source code of the ps5
and then somehow jumps itself into
alternative games
again relatable when was the last time
you played a ps5 game that was trying to
understand the ps5
i've never played i've played so many
games
in my life across all platforms
and never once was the purpose of the
game
playing thousands of games across
platforms never once
was the purpose of the game to
understand the console that i was
playing it on
it's pretty simple and you can take
these kind of curt
girdley m.c eschery
douglas huffstattery
donald hoffmany
understandings of the nature of reality
and you can logically reason and deduce
your way
to realization of infinity
of singularity
expressive power is what gives rise to
its incompleteness
so literally the infinite creation
is what gives rise to the fact that
intelligent infinity is incomplete
so intelligent infinity is an incomplete
completeness so every moment is complete
perfection as it is
yet it's perpetually on a journey
incomplete
eternally exploring all possibility
there's the fractal shirt for i
am a strange loop
turn around and point at itself like a
television camera pointing at the screen
to which it is sending
its image so david hilbert
rigorously ground all of mathematics in
an axiomatic framework
and that's exactly what we're trying to
do with metaphysics
inherent instability belonging to the
summit itself
meaning literally ines the summit
is inherently unstable
or another way to say this is the summit
of infinite creation
is purposely inherently instable
to perpetuate itself exploring all
possibility
and same thing with the inus the inis
has to be perpetually unstable
for you to not know what's going on
as in the character in the grand theft
auto game
can't just all of a sudden know all of
the source code
it's purposely asleep in the dream game
so that it can undergo the process of
waking up and remembering
both true and unprovable lack of proof
is a direct consequence of its truth
boom
upside down reasoning from a would-be
theorem downwards rather than from
axioms upwards
reasoning from a hidden meaning now this
in itself should be enough
for people to recognize that what they
have to do is they have to take this
leap of faith to create this
upside down reasoning from
one infinite creator from intelligent
infinity
from god from infinite consciousness
from a conscious singularity
and then would be theorem downwards
from that leap of faith from that
intuitive
intellectual reasoned logical grocking
and then you understand the nature of
reality
our collective quest for truth
indescribably subtle
sacred girdle contains the word god
strange loops upside down causality
a creature that knows next to nothing of
the substrate allowing its thinking to
happen
nonetheless it knows all about its
symbolic interpretation of the world
knows very intimately something it calls
i
become aware of our brains in high-level
non-physical
terms all right
so here is a little visualization
and go through
so again we're playing with this black
hole
no i empty void
shunya and then
that's this is where the comprehension
is happening
right here and this is your god son
this is i the mirage of
i and what you have is you have this is
what's called the
essence again this is
buddhism essence and then this
is the expression on this side and what
is expression it is
costumes names forms symbols concepts
and so you can have an impure expression
of separation of ego
manipulation and you can have a pure
expression of unity of oneness of love
of wisdom
harmony and so
all of our illusory conditioning
it tethers us so all these illusions
of conditioning they tether us and
these are the mirages neurotic
distortions
so the mirage's neurotic distortions are
all of these illusory conditioning
tethers where we get triggered
by this conditioning because we haven't
yet liberated ourselves
from this minefield of conditioning and
we haven't created the shift yet
into this more and more pure state of
awareness love light
and then recognize that even that very
god-sun-eyness is actually
a simulated attribute the sense of i is
even a mirage it is even a hallucination
itself
and so this is the shift into awakening
so it's simultaneously from impurity to
purity
and that also creates this turn inward
all the way
or you could say the turn inward all the
way is what creates the shift from
impurity to purity
and that's what's written here is that
awakening is deconditioning
the illusion awakening is deconditioning
the illusion
so downward causality think about brains
in the truest way
the micro stuff inside them is pushed
around by ideas and desires
metaphysical idealism
and ultimately all of those dualities
are
transcended between
consciousness and physicalism
concepts symbols most adults
daily mental reality
we perceive essentially nothing at the
level of the invisible components that
intellectually we know we are made out
of
we swim in the world of everyday
concepts and it is they
not micro events that define our reality
so it's more so
the way that you relate with a concept
or a symbol or a name or a form
that defines your reality then it is a
neuron
i this high abstraction behind the
scenes
comes to feel like the maximally real
entity in the universe
strange loop that makes an eye where it
is found how it arises and stabilizes
and i love this terminology down here
episodic projectory
so this also relates to future authoring
episodic projectory so this is your
north star
your calling so the more that you can
project
out and author your future
the more that you're tied into this
north star to this calling to this
actualizing of a unique gift into the
world
and so that has to do with both this
turn inward as well as in this
expression outward
so i is the root the god sun pure aware
being
and what gives rise or what powers
i so you just give that a thought for a
moment stay with that
what gives rise to i
what powers i so the very
life force itself from the big bang
until now
that life force is what powers i
that is me i am the life force i'm the
entirety of the life force
i'm the entirety of the big bang in the
universe i am that all
i'm all of it so you're shifting your
identity from this contracted person to
the entire universe the god state
and in doing so you liberate yourself of
all of your contractions
and you become more and more purely in
service to life awakening because you
recognize it's all you
so your nature is the very source that
gave rise to the
hallucination of i
your nature is the source that gave rise
to the mirage of consciousness
experiencing this dream
the eye seems to each of us to be the
root
undo the decades of brainwashing by
culture and language the millions of
years of human evolution preparing the
way
human brain housing a loop of
self-representation
self-symbol is enriched rendered more
complex by
attachment so the more attached you are
to your sense of self to your sense of
i the more you're triggered the less you
are free the less you are
equanimous you see there's this deep
profound connection here between i am a
strange loop
and awakening it's so profoundly
beautiful
building up my sense of who i am in
others eyes
myself symbol is coalescing out of an
initial void
idealized image one forms of oneself
suffer from our neuroses
a fictitious fictitious
fictitious illusory self
imaginative creation
fictitious illusory self
aspects of this image are illusory
harmful neurotic distortions
one tries to change one's own neurotic
tendencies
the self-reaching and attempting
deliberately to affect
deep changes in itself that's ultimately
the spiritual journey is the turn inward
so the more that you recognize the truth
of your distortions and neuroses
and the more that you reach inward to
dissolve that subconscious conditioning
with love
light acceptance the more you'll create
the space for the god state to set in
stuff i give rise external action
consequences bouncing back
metamorphosizing eye
so there's a feedback loop that happens
and it constantly metamorphosizes the
eye
and here's another way to say that is
the loop of symbol sparking actions and
repercussions triggering symbols
innermost essence locks itself ever more
rigidly into our mind i
converges and stabilizes itself
so be more neuroplastic and be less
rigid and ossified it's pretty simple
be more adaptable be more elastic
be more empty of eye of self
of concept symbols
upward leap from raw stimuli to symbols
that imbues the loop with strangeness
shape stable whirl i the density of i
we get to this world
so the i grew in complexity ever realer
to itself
the chance that any alternative eye less
way of understanding the world could
emerge and compete with it was being
rendered essentially nil
so again this place so deeply into
awakening the eyeless way
so if you don't turn inward
and begin deconstructing yourself
you will have this sense of i
ossify
so universal soul equals god highest
self-representation so mosquitoes
dogs small souls large souls
self-representation far simpler than
that of an adult human and for that
reason
a dog has a far smaller soul
algorithmic equivalent of self-awareness
so one way to look at this is that
there's
localized electromagnetic algorithm
in the dream determines the density of
awareness love light
all
what's going on in the formless ocean of
the dream
there are these electromagnetic
ways to understand the density of
consciousness or the evolution of
consciousness or the awakening level of
consciousness
of awareness love light and so that's
where you can see both
everything has one homogenous dream
substrate but you can also see it
gradiented
like the prismatically refracted white
light
based on the seven densities
based on the stage of awakening
i am not provable
huh
it's like this this is trying to prove
itself
like this is trying to like go back
trace trace itself back to its source
and like prove itself
so funny
evolutionary pressures gradually made
brains
grow more complex and multi-layered
eventually
categories grew so rich that the system
was
capable of pointing back at itself it's
not matter
it's energy so it's not
physical it's spiritual it's energetic
keep going what's below subatomic
particles quarks
what's below plonks
take your subatomic corks what's below
that plonks
what are plonks energy
it ain't the meat it's the motion right
so it's not that physical
it's that energetic it's the motion of
the ocean
so shift our attention to a far higher
level of brain activity in order to find
symbols concepts meanings desires and
ultimately ourselves
so here's another way to visualize it
you have this third density human
you have the sixth density higher self
the calling seventh density god
and so you keep attention on north star
calling perpetually and you make the
shift
from the person to the god state
the starring role is played instead by
an atomically invisible murky thing
called eye
shadowy players ideas thoughts memories
beliefs hopes fears intentions desires
ethereal neurology free world of these
players
i pusher and a mover star player useful
shorthand for a myriad of infinitesimal
entities in the invisible chemical
transactions taking place among them by
the billions nay
the millions of billions every second
neither species can see or even imagine
the lower levels of a reality that is
nonetheless central to its existence
one pulsating energy matrix
many neuroscientists great familiarity
with the low-level aspects of the brain
makes them skeptical that consciousness
of free will
could ever be explained in physical
terms at all an unbridgeable chasm
between mind and matter
one conscious infinite energy
see there's still so much
duality that needs to be transcended by
awakening
the two are always ultimately one
simultaneity so these are visuals of
that strange looping
self-reference self-reference
self-reference self-reference
self-reference
huh
uh
this is probably one of the most
important visuals that you'll see in the
book
this inis is the swirling galaxy
and here is your eye that black hole
in the middle of the galaxy
the very illusion mirage hallucination
that has name concepts form family
career meaning
symbols all of these things swirling
around it
and so you can add a little spectrum
here where you have on one side you have
the easier
to be empty when you're alone so when
you're by yourself you're like i'm the
universe
and then when there's two people five
people you have a zoom call you're at a
party
more eyes is more swirls
which makes it harder to be empty
because
you have all of these things that are
triggered
all of these are triggered as these
swirls of galaxies come together
we'll have a visual for that in a bit
professional neuroscientist is not by
any means synonymous with understanding
the brain deeply
no more than being a professional
physicist is synonymous with
understanding hurricanes deeply
sometimes being mired down in gobs of
detailed knowledge is the exact thing
that blocks deep understanding
the vast swirling galaxy of inis a locus
of causality
perceived hard sphericity of that marble
in our minds that we attribute
to it a reality as great as that of
anything we know
locking in of the eye symbol that
inevitably takes place over years and
years in the feedback loop of human
self-perception
causality gets turned around and i seems
to be in the driver's seat
strange loop of selfhood human
self-perception inevitably ends up
positing an emergent
entity that exerts an upside down
causality on the world
leading to the intense reinforcement of
and the final invincible
immutable locking in of this belief the
end result is often the vehement denial
of the possibility of any alternative
point of view at all
so a big part of the game is to create
more
of a bounciness for you to play with
your sense of eye with your sense of
self
to not get so triggered when that's
happening when
awareness is being shined on your
conditioning
spirit of the hive and teleci hollands
inteleki hollands
emergent self-referential emergent
self-referential comprehending elan
vital
an emergent self-referential
comprehending life force
emergent self-referential comprehending
life force can't really get much simpler
than that in describing the nature of
reality
the most important facet of all of those
human beings is their own sense of self
so when you have a bare strange loop of
selfhood it does not give rise to a
distinct self requires contact with
something else in the world in order to
start acquiring a distinctive identity a
distinctive
eye
and that's when you can do things like
recognize that
when people are empty when they're more
like this mirror consciousness
what happens is that their only
distinctive sense of identity
comes up to serve the
unblocking of the entities
blockages
same members infinite regress
no answer is yielded
all right so here's another important
visualization
so in this one you have
you have the chameleon consciousness
organism
elasticity spiral surfer there are many
ways to describe this on one side
you have that emptiness on the other
side you have the fullness on one side
you have the mirror
on the other side you have the architect
and so on the emptiness there's no
memory
right you see it dissolving no memory
but on this full side on the architect
side you see a conceptual lattice
something that's very polymathic right
so the whole point of the game is to be
able to do both
this is the chameleon consciousness this
is
being at that most awakened state
and yet also being at the most literate
state in science and engineering and
form
and art and politics and maximizing
potential on that side meeting the
sustainable development goals
and that's where this empty desktop
analogy continues
where you have that very untriggerable
deconditioned
yet you're accessing concepts as needed
to architect
and that's where that nirmanikaya
rainbow expression comes in again
so this is the nirmanakaya rainbow
expression
so that very empty fullness is the
neuronicae rainbow expression
it's when you're so
beautifully profoundly empty and yet
you're simultaneously
expressing the most pure expression
of creation possible in service to
it awakening
so the realization of human selfhood
is not nearly so automatic and
genetically predetermined as that would
suggest
closing of the strange loop of human
selfhood is deeply dependent
perception categorization richer and
more powerful an organism's
categorization equipment is
the more realized and rich will be
itself
poorer in organisms repertoire of
categories the more impoverished will be
the self
until in the limit there simply is no
self
at all see so much similarities with the
awakening
i love it
in babies there exists no strange loop
of selfhood or nearly none
no i more generous some minimal dollop
of inis
two individuals each of whom have their
own personal identity their own private
strange loop
part of that private identity is made
out of and is thus dependent upon the
private identity
of the other individual the more the
private identities
of the two loops are intertwined and the
more
they start to be fused blurred and even
to coin a word
undisentanglable from each other
so we'll look at a visual of this soon
there will be many loops of different
sizes and degrees of complexity
meet tarzan eugene our naming convention
not only supports but enormously helps
to lock
in the comfortable notion that we
ourselves are cleanly separated entities
me tarzan eugene end of story
and the exact opposite is true
language plays a further role gives us
personal pronouns me
you reinforce the notion of a crystal
clear sharp distinction between souls
yeah i would say that the pronoun
me you
that
those play one of the greatest roles
along with
name and not being able to see under the
costume
for keeping people asleep to the
interdependence and interconnection of
all that is
okay so here's the visualization right
so here's what you get when you put
two
of these spiral
eye galaxies next to each other
so especially if these are like if this
is a family relationship
like you've been together for decades
like this is a minefield
basically and especially if one of them
like this one is in the third density
and so and this and this one is in the
fifth density so
this one appears in the
third density i
as right here so you see this here it's
appearing here
within this eyes swirl
whereas this one is appearing here
right within this swirl
and so here you can see that there's
many different shared concepts memory
symbols there's a bunch of triggerables
over here and yet this one because it's
fifth density it's more empty it's more
ascended and it's holding space for
unblocking
this one and so this is how you can view
the different chakras and how
these entities can help each other
one that's more empty can serve in the
unblocking
and the awakening of the other one
that's why the more awakened you are
the more you're responsible for life
awakening
so that's a helpful
visualization
two or more bodies sharing a single self
and so you can see this will get a lot
more complex once you start adding in a
third one
fourth one fifth one etc
wedding ceremony is a soul merger giving
rise to a single unit having just
one higher level soul like two drops of
water coming together touching and then
seamlessly fusing
showing that sometimes one plus one
equals one
although we were distinct individuals
that distinctness seemed to fade away to
vanish almost
entirely when it came to parenthood
the same hopes and dreams can inhabit
two different people's brains
in some dimensions of life turned us
into a single unit
that acted as a whole much as a school
of fish
acts as a single-minded higher level
entity
and so here you see one person will say
something like money
which is one concept idea symbol and
this person will think of x y z this
person will think of 4 5 6
z this person will think of triangle ttp
this person will think of square square
triangle circle this person will think
of car
watch and so you have you have all these
billions of interpretations
some overlap most don't
so here's the little overlaps and so now
what about if you change the word if you
change the word to dad or love or
politics or religion or sports
what kind of what kind of
will happen in the different
senses of i and so the more empty you
are the less of a
that arises
the name carol denotes for me a very
vast
pattern a style that's his former
wife before she passed
having a significant percentage of the
person
their self their soul their eye their
consciousness their interiority
would exist at some point along the
spectrum sufficiently large pattern
fraction of the actual pattern
of the view from inside
so carol's own personal sense of
i is represented in my brain for brief
periods of time in conversations or even
in non-verbal moments of intense feeling
i was carol just as that time
she was dug had brought into existence a
somewhat blurry coarse grain
copy of itself in my brain had created a
second dairy godelian
swirl
self structures a lifetime of locking in
and self stabilizing given rise to an
eye
so a strange loop city country
civilization galaxy universe
give you the whole universe like a
strange loop
loops of self are isomorphic with
different flavorings
chameleons import the spices of other
people's lives history spices that imbue
their self loops with unique
individuality
we are capable of seeing the world
through their eyes their psychic point
of view is transportable and modular not
trapped inside
and so good questions and putting people
on the chopping block can catalyze
awakening
so here you have i1 and i2 are
structurally
similar and yet they have different
flavors
and so the better that you get at
seeing the patterns of these
densities of consciousness awakening the
more
you can help serve the unblocking
of destructive conditioning patterns
that prevent people from awakening to
the true nature of reality
to the true nature of them is god
so a girdle turing threshold a computer
can emulate any kind of machine
so one single universal machine morphs
into new
functionalities the critical threshold
for this kind of computational
universality comes
at exactly that point where a machine is
flexible
enough to read and correctly interpret a
set of data that describe its own
structure
a machine can in principle explicitly
watch how it does any particular task
step by step
a machine that
has this critical level of flexibility
can imitate any other machine
no matter how complex the ladder is
there's nothing more flexible than a
universal machine universality
is as far as you can go
so imagine becoming universal in your
consciousness in your awareness
and noticing that great now i've
unlocked this
peak level of awakening so now what i do
is i serve
the rest of the universe awakening
because it's all me
people are represented by symbols a self
is also a concept
inhabited to varying extents by other
eyes
so there's an affinity of souls rapidly
come to know each other's
essences great potential to live inside
each other
so you can think about this like let me
inside you especially for a guru or
someone that's awakened or someone
that's trying to help you
let me inside you is the fastest way to
awaken consciousness is to
recognize that you're being served and
to
put your psychology your conditioning
your [ __ ]
on the chopping block
so consciousness is densities of energy
patterns
it's very profound consciousness as
densities of energy patterns
consciousness or patterns
so the whole one body one person one
brain one soul is the caged bird
metaphor
humans are social beings constituting
many strange loop patterns
humans are social beings constituting
many strange loop patterns
so there is of course a principled
domicile a main brain for each
particular eye
an internal conflict between several
rival selves
so how many souls just one so the closer
you are to one
infinite creator the more there's only
one
me so there's no more arguing there's no
more rival selves
rival selves in arguing come from when
the separate
person is arguing with the one infinite
creator
that's central intelligence and so this
is one of the ways to look at
spirituality
is that on this side you have this ego
separate sense of self this is the third
density
and then the shift this is the delta
this is the change
to the god self the seventh density
pretty simple the entire spiritual
journey is just
ending the argument stopping
being the egoic separate self and
shifting into
alignment with the universe the god
self
they would come to live more and more
inside each other the sense of a clear
boundary
between them would slowly be dissolved
it's beautiful
our souls really do inter penetrate and
blur
together this is also called unilocality
too messy too scary an idea for us to
deal with so we insist
instead that there is no genuine overlap
like distant galaxies
our lifelong ingrained habit is to
accept without question the caged bird
metaphor for souls
and it's very hard to break out of such
a profoundly rooted habit
so when you really get how reality
everything in reality every
particle interpenetrates every particle
energetically
that's when you recognize the unity
substrate of all
existence and you stop creating these
artificial
boundaries between people
now there's no separation but that's not
to say that there's not unique
individuation
which is cool there's an individuation
in non-duality
a self-ass analogous to a country with
embassies in many other countries
the word love cannot be separated from
the word i
i love that one such a good one
consciousness is the dance of symbols
consciousness is thinking
so just to take you back here for a
moment that
when you understand that the eye is
shared that this whole
electromagnetic dream universal field
that we are is shared
you understand that that's what love is
that's what absolute love is
and any other human conception of love
is
absolute blasphemy
it's madness
take a complex situation and to put
one's finger on what matters in it
distill from an initial welter of
sensations and ideas
to spot the gist
so peak synthesis do
simplify while not letting essence slip
away
boom love that
okay so
[Music]
i isn't housed anywhere self-reinforcing
structure self-reinforcing story
self-reinforcing
myth
i is something created out of nothing
i is a self-referencing mirage
i am hallucinated into existence
i as a hallucination perceived by a
hallucination
i as a hallucination hallucinated by a
hallucination
so here's the intertwining with
spirituality taoism and zen long ago
were dismantling and deconstructing
getting rid of the eye
the story of an eye is a tale about a
central essence that never disappears
from view
this little pronoun is the nexus of all
that makes our human existence
mysterious and mystical
intrinsically self-pointing loop that
the pronoun i
involves different from all other
structures in the universe
don't have the ability to see deeply
enough into my substrate to make my eye
poof out of existence
and i wrote lol describing nirvana
[Music]
so basically when you do have the
ability to see deep enough into
the substrate of your existence to make
your eye poof
out of reality is nirvana being blown
away
being blown out
but most people are so stuck in their
eye that they can't
access this door to cessation
of the eye so the
tool won't taste nirvana until they turn
inward
a level crossing feedback loop whose
apparent solidity dominates the reality
of everything else in the world
this eye this unreal but unutterably
stubborn marble in the mind
this epiphenomenon simply takes over
anointing itself as reality number one
and from there on
out it won't go away
no matter what words are spoken
self-inquiry that turn inward
objectifying
sensations and perceptions and
recognizing them as not
i liberates you creates more equanimity
creates more freedom
and then that's where you recognize the
formless existence
of that very black hole comprehending
infinite creation
so again a big part of awakening is
turning inward
and investigating the sense of i
so i is like paper money
a hallucination yet supports the whole
economy
so decentralization is like the social
memory complex
so ultimately the eye is a hallucination
and yet paradoxically it is the most
precious thing we own as dan dennett
points out unconsciousness explained
an i is a little like a bill of paper
money it feels
as if it is worth a great deal but
ultimately it is just the social
convention a kind of illusion
that we all tactically agree on without
ever having been asked and which despite
being illusory supports our entire
economy
and yet the bill is just a piece of
paper with no intrinsic worth at all
so again it's a great analogy i is like
paper money a hallucination yet it
supports the whole economy
and decentralization of the eye or of
the paper money into bitcoin is like
the social memory complex
that's what we are evolving to in the
evolution of consciousness is towards
that
social memory complex that's transparent
that's honest
no lies no deception
the strange loop of selfhood will
automatically arise in any sufficiently
sophisticated repertoire of categories
once you've got itself you've got
consciousness
various universes to be entities inside
of a greater metaverse
this is really important the metaverse
contains all these possible
[Music]
universes
[Music]
so mohandas gandhi eleanor roosevelt
mother teresa
martin luther king
more conscious greater souls
magnamine magnanimity
generosity latin having a great soul
mahatma great soul etymology compassion
latin suffering along with that's great
so the more you turn
up your compassion the more you're able
to suffer along with people and then to
help them
unblock and awaken and provide planetary
architectures to support that process
and that's what creates this having a
great soul
so turning into awakening
tuning into awakening all that is is the
largest soul
god so the more that you tune into the
vibration of awakening all of
life that's when you're tapped into that
god soul
so partial internalization of other
creatures interiority
will most clearly marks off creatures
who have large souls from creatures that
have small souls
so the more that you can take on that
other perspective
the more large of a soul you have
so yardstick for measuring consciousness
can also be thought of as musical taste
which is really interesting if you think
about it typically the more that people
listen to
the most mainstream music or the more
that people eat at the most
mainstream fast food restaurants so the
more that the people
that consume the most mainstream sources
of
news and television and media
you can think about that like the
smaller or of a solar the dimmer of a
light of consciousness that they have
those who strike us as selfless are in
fact
very soulful they house many
other souls inside their own enlarges
and enriches it
so experiencing consciousness selfless
is soulful the power to know
is consciousness is pure bare and empty
and that is the root experience
consciousness is the rude experience the
power to know is the rude experience
selfless people are soulful
the gulf between our self and other
selves
and so awakening is dissolving this gulf
identity inis inner light interiority
menace is more like a shimmering elusive
rainbow so again
shift identity from person to god
i love this ending it's so fantastic
in the end we self-perceiving
self-inventing
locked-in mirages are little miracles of
self-reference
our very nature is such as to prevent us
from fully understanding its very nature
human beings like rainbows and mirages
are unpredictable self-writing poems
the strange loop characterization
of our essences gives us a deeper and
subtler vision
of what it is to be human
the loss of this eye of this self
is worth the gain
so i essence
is self-writing
mirage so i in essence
is a self-writing mirage a
self-inventing hallucination
which is required for us to experience
realities
we have to have this simulated sense of
eye for us to be able to have the
experience
of being a universe
so dissolving i slash
self is massive gains
awakening so again dissolving
the i the sense of self is massive gains
this is awakening it's worth
the gain
love that great so
let's there's one bit back here
that i want to share with you that i
thought was really interesting also
a society of interacting human beings
each of whom has a fairly accurate
self-image and less accurate image of
others
often based on very quick and inaccurate
glances
so people that are good friends know
each other well
whereas strangers have rough partial or
vacuous representations of each other
this is really important when people are
asked about hey what do you
think or feel about this person it's
like
i'm not good friends with them they're
stranger to me you know i'm one with
them but they're stranger to me i don't
have any representation
and so we are so quick
to judge especially on the internet
people that we
don't even know
much of the structure of the eye
involves pointers that point right back
at the abstraction i
and not just at the body so literally i
is pointing at itself
the abstraction of i it's not pointing
at the body
like i'm not talking about my knee i'm
talking about a memory which is a total
abstraction
deep entangled self model is that is
what eyeness is all about so inis is the
deep entangled self
model
this was beautiful so sir roger penrose
who won the nobel prize in
physics in 2020 who has a cyclic
cosmology
again playing on infinity and recursion
consciousness is a novel kind of quantum
phenomena
which views consciousness as an
intrinsically quantum mechanical
phenomenon again that very
electromagnetic
substrate that is this dream has these
worlds
of i-ness
so consciousness is uniformly pervading
everything
in the universe so you have both the
si you have the simultaneity between the
one homogeneous
existence and substrate the awareness
love light
meanwhile it's also gradiented
refracted prismatically
and so you have those seven densities
where you have the distinctions
where you have somebody that feels like
a contracted person you have someone
else that feels like an awakened god
one person that's trying to serve
themselves and get peace and happiness
out of creation
versus the other person that's
completely empty of all self-interest
and they're just
purely serving creation awakening
they bring peace and happiness to
everything
to you my faithful reader who has plowed
all through this book up to its nearly
final page
i love bits like that they're really
important because
we're we're living in a culture where
we have more and more people that for
some reason
are not
prioritizing doing things like this
where they can where they can
you can get through this book you can do
this
in a matter of days like you can read a
hundred pages a day
and so you can get through a 400 page
book like this in four days
that's about what it takes me when i'm
seriously dedicated but that usually
means that i'm reading like
something like six hours a day
sometimes more like eight and so
if you're dedicating yourself like that
what will happen is
you will be able to fire and wire
so much of the beauty you'll extract
the beauty of this so
it's so saturated with beauty you know
you're basically
getting douglas's hofstetter's
most profound realizations
distilled into a book that you can
finish in four days
and you're gonna learn way more from
that
than you will from trying to scroll
on a social media platform and try and
get
information you're not going to get
information
as deeply
embedded as you will from these types of
processes
so i highly recommend picking up i am a
strange loop picking up girdle usher
bach
picking up just your favorite author's
books
around self-actualization
self-realization the nature of reality
all the good stuff and
reading and
so i'm really grateful
to you doug thank you such a good book
brother
thank you thank you and
also thanks everyone for tuning in we
love you very much
i love you very much thank you and i
hope
this video distillation brought you
tremendous value
i i want to share with you another
sort of visualization
as we wrap
so here you can see another way of sort
of viewing
um what we were exploring there
is that for example if you take
this big bang
and then you view it as this one
intelligence
right this big bang is this one
intelligence and a
fractal emergence so something that's
self-similar yet chaotic
so this fractal emergence and then boom
all of these galaxies
and so you have this comprehension
mechanism
right so the sense of eye that emerges
is a comprehension mechanism for this
one intelligence to understand itself
and that's where you can draw these
parallels where you see that this
absolute black hole pupil is the
comprehension mechanism
and then you have this god sun star as
the enlightenment
right so all these stars so all the
solar systems
in this galaxy and here you have the
very act of perception
itself the very act of awareness or
consciousness
itself as god as enlightenment
light and then you have the planets the
people the iris
so these planets people and
iris as the unique differentiation
so these planets are different the
people on the planets are different the
iris
is different for each of us that dna is
.1 different for each of us
and that's the unique differentiation of
the costume
of the name of the form of the
shape of the wave but yet the ocean
is what everything is and so that's
where you get this
absolute black hole that's where you get
these suns
that's where you get that enlightenment
that pure aware
consciousness bare empty
that formless power to know is a quality
that's shared
and so that's how you can view this is
that a galaxy
looks so similarly
to a pupil to the eye
so the galaxy system and the eye system
so similar like that so one
intelligence fractal emergence
comprehending itself
it's quite uh quite
beautifully simple
so again thanks everyone i would love to
hear
how you feel in the comments below about
what we discussed
and if the video brought you value i'd
love for you to give it a like
and subscribe to the channel if you
haven't yet also share the video with
people that you feel like this would
profoundly
impact
and also do continue drawing the
analogies between
this i am a strange loop and awakening
that'll be really helpful
and the links are in the bio below to i
am a strange loop if you want to
go and purchase it and also
to our own
links in the bio if you want to join our
support those links are below
i am a strange loop
i am a strange loop i
am a strange loop i am a strange loop
i am a strange loop i am a strange loop
ay
i am a strange loop i am
a strange loop i am a strange loop
i am a strange loop ay i am
a strange loop ay i am a strange loop
one infinite mystery
infinite mystery infinite mystery
i am a strange lupe i am a strange loop
a
infinite mystery infinite mystery
so relax fall in love with yourself
you're beautiful perfect as you are
radically love and accept yourself and
all of your [ __ ] trauma conditioning
nonsense
and create the space for yourself to
be god to be
the infinite mystery that this all is
to be the shared infinite oneness
that this all is
and to love it all like that
and to serve it with honor
infinite love
you